d'assurance dentaire.
Laurence Martin.
- Is it a good deal for you,
for Canada, for yoda, for your ?
- Justin Trudeau signale
qu'il n'est pas près de quitter
L'accord signé avec le NPD
permet aux libéraur
au pouvoir jusqu'en 2025.
JUSTIN TRUDEAU,
- D'ici là, le gouvernement
pourra donc fonctionner dans
la stabilité et la prévisibilité
afin de livrer la marchandise
- En échange de
des néodémocrates
lors des votes de confiance,
le gouvernement Trudeau s'engags
priorités du NPD, entre autres,r
les familles moins nanties
et un régime universelments.
- Dans les endroits où il y a
moins d'alignement entre
le NPD et le Parti libéral,
on va être là p autres partis.
- Car il ne s'agit pas
d'un accord de coalition.
Aucun él
partie du Conseil des ministres.
- Des soins de santé
et l'aide aux gens.
- Une heure et demie plus tard,
Jagmeet Singh se défend
de s'être agenouillé
devant le premier ministre.
JAGMEET SINGH, chef,
Nouveau Parti démocratique
- Ce n'est pas du tout
une carte blanche.
rester un parti d'opposition,
on garde le pouvoir de
s'opposer au gouvernement.
- Et même de retirer son appui,
s'il estime que les priorités
communes ne progressent pas
suffisamment.
- Mais on commence
avec une bonne volonté,
avec une bonne voie, le fait
qu'on veut que ça fonctionne.
- C'est un nouveau scandale!
(applaudissements)
- Les conservateurs,
qui ont toujours reproché
à Justin Trudeau d'être trop
à gauche et trop dépensier,
tirent à boulets rouges
sur le gouvernement libéral.
- Plus de dépenses, plus
de taxes et de moins en moins
de respect pour le Parlement.
- Le Bloc estime que
les provinces, comme le Québec,
sont les grandes perdantes.
YVES-FRANÇOIS BLANCHET,
chef, Bloc québécois
- Je comprends que la base
de l'entente, c'est de piétiner
les juridictions du Québec
et des provinces en matière
de santé, d'assurance dentaire,
d'assurance médicaments.
- Avec la stabilité que procure
cette entente, Justin Trudeau
compte profiter des prochaines
années pour asseoir son héritage
et faire avancer ses grands
dossiers. Et même si cet accord
donne des munitions aux partis
d'opposition en Chambre,
les bloquistes viennent dennente
perdre un levier de négociation
important; les conservateurs,
eux, une chance à court terme
de reprendre le pouvoir.
Ici Lauin,
Radio-Canada, Ott